[Música]
estaba acostada en mi cama en una mano
tiene una bolsa de papitas está comiendo
con esta otra mano me estaba sumando acá
en los hombros es en esta parte de la
espalda donde se acumula mi estrés y
tensión estaba cansada estaba agotada
era un viernes por la noche estaba acaba
de llegar de una jornada de más de 12
horas de trabajo
y mientras veían netflix me ponía a
pensar si realmente lo que yo estaba
haciendo con mi carrera tenía un impacto
contar y cubrir historias tan negativas
pues muchas veces te drena la energía me
preguntaba si tenía un impacto positiva
en la sociedad y también me estaba
cuestionando si combinar mi trabajo en
los medios de comunicación con este
proyecto de radio comunitaria que
acababa de empezar hacía unos meses
valía la pena vale la pena tanto estrés
tantos nervios tan tener jeta negativa
pues justamente cuando me estaba
preguntando en eso me llega un mensaje y
llega un mensaje de louis así le voy a
decir para cuidar su identidad y su
integridad un chavo de 15 años de edad
de 3º de secundaria con el que había
estado ya trabajando hace un par de
meses tanto con él como con otros chavos
habíamos estado trabajando un proyecto
de radio comunitaria
louis me escribía en este mensaje que
era momento de intentar alejarse de las
drogas
que era momento de ponerse a chambear de
ponerse a estudiar de concentrarse en
terminar la secundaria en la prepa y
luego estudiar periodismo porque el
hecho de tener un arma en las manos le
gustaba más que tener
y el hecho de tener un micrófono en las
manos le gustaba más que tener un arma
en las manos le gustaba más que estarse
rogando todo el tiempo fue ahí cuando
dije vamos bien
los medios de comunicación a mí me han
dado la oportunidad de tener una
plataforma para contar historias buenas
y malas pero al fin y al cabo historias
también mellado de la oportunidad de
aprender de conocer de enseñar pero
sobre todo de analizar de poder
comprender a la sociedad he logrado
entender por qué la sociedad está tan
está en el en el cañón lo he podido
entender así que fue por eso que
empezamos con este proyecto de radio
comunitaria donde los chavos tenían una
oportunidad de hablar por fin el podcast
que ellos grababan semana a semana era
escuchado por alguien por fin tenía
estaba teniendo un impacto positivo y
ahí fue donde comprendí que las radios
comunitarias en el país han tenido un se
han convertido en un sistema de
resistencia porque es a través de estas
redes comunitarias donde las personas de
una colonia o de cierta parte de la
ciudad a través de sus medios con lo que
ellos puedan cuentan las historias que
están pasando en sus comunidades y es
ahí en esos momentos cuando ellos
cuentan sus historias la historia del
sacerdote que en la colonia ayuda a
todos la iglesia que reúne ahí que le da
un techo y un pan que comer cada día a
las personas que no tienen una casa es
ahí cuando se forma un sentido de
identidad
recuerdo por ejemplo un día también que
me di cuenta que era necesario llevarlos
más allá de los medios de comunicación
para mi cabina 47 ha sido un espacio
donde semana a semana me reúno con
chavos de entre los 15 y los 20 años de
edad nos reunimos tres o cuatro días y
aprendemos sí sobre la voz sobre cómo
respirar correctamente al hablar en
público aprendemos la diferencia entre
dicción y entre gesticular pero también
es un lugar donde llegamos cada día y
nos abrazamos
es un lugar donde nos vemos a los ojos
ahí fue cuando entendí que teníamos que
hacer esa clase de clic esa clase de
dinámicas porque al principio cuando yo
les intentaba enseñar sobre comunicación
los chavos eran muy agresivos no existía
el trabajo en equipo porque era muy
agresivo esos trabajos en equipo
terminaban en peleas en golpes uno
buscando al otro así que por eso les
dije saben que vamos a cambiar la
dinámica cada vez que llegábamos les
pedía que caminaran por el espacio que
se pusiera un objetivo caminaban a su
objetivo y llegaban luego les pedía que
caminaban hacia otro objetivo tal vez
una puerta o una ventana caminaban y
llegaban a otro objetivo pero luego les
pedí que cada vez que intentaran caminar
por el espacio y que llegaran a sus
objetivos si se topaban en el camino con
uno de sus compañeros que lo vieran a
los ojos luego que lo sonrieran luego
que lo abrazaran después de eso pasamos
ejercicios de confianza tenemos un
escritorio y todos se tenían que aventar
del escritorio se subían se ponían de
espaldas
había varias personas acá abajo y lo
agarra vamos no importaba qué tan pesado
o qué tan menudita o chaparro o alta
estuvieras lo íbamos a agarrar fue ahí
cuando empezamos a ver cambios a los
tres meses
sergio ya sonreía sergio un chavo que
tres meses atrás yo le puse una vez mi
mano en su hombro y se puso muy tenso me
pidió que no lo tocara esa misma clase
cuando sergio me pidió que no le tocara
el hombro vi que una chava como que no
comprendía lo que yo le decía era fátima
que acaba de llegar a territorio
mexicano había estado toda su vida
creciendo en eeuu pero ahora tenía que
estar aquí porque su mamá acababa de ser
deportada
empezamos a hacer estos ejercicios de
los que les platicaba sergio ya sonreía
fátima los tres meses ya hablaba un poco
más fluida de hecho se convirtió en una
de nuestras productoras de radio ella
andaba siempre dirigiendo las chavas de
los chavos por ejemplo también alma
mejoró sus calificaciones habían que ya
no le daba tanta pena exponer louis
comenzaba a dejar las drogas así fue
como fuimos cambiando sin embargo no
todo fue fácil como nada en la vida
cabina 47 ahora camina creativa es un
espacio que se ha desarrollado una
estación de radio comunitaria que éste
se desenvuelve en un espacio que ha sido
marginado donde hay mucha pobreza donde
hay mucha violencia así que por eso es
muy común ver que los chavos lo que les
decía se golpeaban entre ellos se
burlaban pero empezamos a ver los
cambios positivos después de estas
dinámicas y ejercicios que les empecé a
contar entonces cuál es mi propuesta
aquí
yo no les digo que construyan una
estación de radio estaría padrísimo que
lo hicieran pero no es necesariamente
obligatorio lo que sí creo que debemos
de hacer si somos personas que estamos
comprometidos con nuestra sociedad si
somos personas que queremos saber
cambios empiecen a trabajar con personas
empiezan a trabajar ya cuestionar a sus
compañeros de trabajo a sus hijos a sus
hermanos empiecen a platicar con ellos
la radio es una herramienta que sana y
no lo digo yo lo dice sergio quien ya
mantiene la mirada fija cuando habla con
alguien lo dice fátima quien ahora es
muy fluida en español quien ya se graduó
de la secundaria y quien aparte del
discurso de su generación en español
lo dice luis quien lleva más de seis
meses limpio sin ingerir drogas sin
tomar un arma lo viste rogelio bueno lo
dicen los amigos de rogelio que aquí ya
no los volea en la preparatoria los dice
también alma que ya ha mejorado su
relación con su mamá debido a que ahora
sí se atreve expresar sus sentimientos
lo dice bien acá
kim ya logró entrar a la universidad lo
dice el proyecto de la colifata de
argentina una organización no
gubernamental que tiene ya más de 28
años trabajando en un hospital
psiquiátrico donde trabaja con las
personas que están internadas a través
de diferentes herramientas de
comunicación particularmente de radio y
bueno los resultados que han tenido las
personas que están ahí han sido
increíbles ha mejorado mucho su calidad
de vida y tanto su salud así que está
una propuesta en la que les platico
lleguen hoy con sus hijos a su casa y
pregúnteles cómo estás que te gusta te
gusta más el rojo o el azul o prefieres
unos tacos o prefieres una hamburguesa
que se sienten que son escuchados que
alguien se preocupa por ellos y que
alguien realmente quiere conocer
una vez que hacen eso vuelven a
preguntar lo mismo al día siguiente pero
ahora los miran a los ojos
luego pueden preguntarles también lo
mismo pero ahora le agregan el cómo
estuvo tu día y agregan una sonrisa al
final de su pregunta esto lo pueden
hacer con compañeros de trabajo con tus
hijos con tus amigos con un grupo con
los vecinos con quien sea pero hagan lo
que sienten realmente esa intención de
ustedes de saber cómo ha ido su día
después de eso pudieran un poco
experimentar con la voz ya que tienen la
confianza o joaquín y paréntesis si una
de las personas con las que ustedes les
preguntan no quiere hablar está bien
poco a poco ellos van a ir entrando en
confianza poco a poco cuando vean que le
preguntan a otras personas y que esas
otras preguntas contestan las respecto y
responden las preguntas que ustedes
están haciendo ellos solos se van a ir
abriendo entonces ya que entraron en
confianza luego pueden empezar a
preguntar siempre has vivido aquí esta
es tu comunidad de donde vinieron tus
papás
conoces a tus papás
para entrar en confianza y luego pueden
tal vez hacer un ejercicio con la voz
experimenten de eso se trata de
experimentar de jugar de que somos
capaces que es lo que traemos acá
adentro una vez que logran todo eso
pueden encontrar un momento del día para
irse a tomar una botella de agua o un
café es importante que encuentren un
lugar que esté en silencio y es muy
difícil encontrar un lugar que esté en
silencio todos corremos tan deprisa
todos vamos corriendo por todos lados
pero también es ahí en esos momentos de
caos y de crisis cuando valoramos el
silencio
una vez que crean esta atmósfera de
confianza de tranquilidad y de silencio
saquen su celular creo que ahora la
mayoría de nosotros tenemos acceso a un
teléfono inteligente y pueden empezar a
grabar sus voces con las notas de voz
que vienen en cada uno de sus celulares
pueden tal vez cantar juntos pero graben
si una vez que terminan de grabar se lo
escuchan es increíble el sentimiento que
te da escucharte a ti mismo fuera de ti
mismo y no me dejará mentir estoy segura
que aquí en más de un
ha escuchado ha vuelto a escuchar las
notas de voz que enviaron por whatsapp
después de que fueron recibidas o que ya
fueron leídas por alguien todos hemos
escuchado es nuestras notas de voz y
hemos vuelto a escuchar las notas de voz
de alguien más
así que escuchen se hablen con la otra
persona
y es así como poco a poco van a empezar
a ver cambios es importante ayudar a las
otras personas ayudar a nuestro prójimo
a conectar con ellos mismos a través de
su voz es nuestra voz la que nos ayuda a
sacar todo lo que tenemos acá adentro es
nuestra voz también la que nos ayuda a
hablar con el otro y sobre todo es
nuestra voz la que nos ayuda a sanar
gracias
[Aplausos]